[Music]
Megan is in Buffalo New York hi Megan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
taking my call
sure what's up I'm 32 and when I was in
my early 20s my family used to pay for
everything for me so you used to bail me
out financially hurry I kind of lived
off for a long time but in the last
couple of unity I've just kind of I made
a complete 180 I'm showing all of your
stuff is - it's really really helpful
they keep trying to bail me out of
everything like lately my mom doesn't
like my name apartment and she breaking
up on it you have to stand still or
something to speak directly into it I
can't hear half of what you're saying
can you hear me now yes I can thank you
okay so my family keeps trying to bail
me out financially I don't need bailing
out anymore did I understand that part
right I mean I you know I am you know I
am in a slight debt but I don't want
them to help me anymore I don't want to
accept any of their help so I wasn't
sure if you come in come in like a
productive conversation know that I can
have with them or if I should just sit
down with them and kind of go over my
finance plans okay so what do you what
do you make a year breaking up again
honey okay and you make what I can make
anywhere from 16 to 18 thousand dollars
a year mm-hmm and you don't and they
don't think you can live on that okay
well I I mean that's that's just weird
yeah I mean work yeah well I guess I
just got accustomed to taking care of
you and she doesn't like the apartment
you live in but if you're paying your
own bills it's none of her business
yeah so I guess I mean I don't know I'm
I don't my point is is they're being so
weird I'm not sure there is a productive
conversation that's going to work you
can try and the thing you try just say
listen thank you so much for all the
help all those years ago I really
appreciate it
listen I'm making you know close to 60
maybe even up to $80,000 and I don't
need any help and you should you should
be like excited for me then I don't need
help and thank you but thank you for
your generous offer and no I'm not going
to receive any more help from you but
thank you you're very kind and
appreciate you offering it no and then
what would the response be if you said
that to your mother very angry okay then
there well then they've got issues yeah
see they want to run your life still
right yeah I mean is there some reason
they should have control over your life
I don't know and that's why I wasn't
sure I know and you know yeah you know
is there some reason that they need to
have control over your life I think they
think I can't do it so I you know I
guess that's what frustrates me I mean
okay let me do this the book you need to
pick up it's called boundaries by dr.
Henry cloud because you're your parents
don't have boundaries
they're weird okay they're sweet they
mean well but they're weird okay if you
have a 32 year old daughter making 80
grand and you insult her by continually
offering money to her and if she doesn't
take it you get mad you're weird
by definition okay just just when you
run that out in a sentence like that it
just sounds strange doesn't it yeah
you're not crazy they are okay you're
just trying to be normal but they got
used to helping you somewhere back there
they've got maybe they've guessing they
make a lot of money right I mean
you know they make decent money it's not
you know upper-class sort of thing no
it's not that okay they're not like uber
rich then right well then this is really
weird I mean if they if they made them
if they had millions of dollars or
something and they're like hey I can
throw you a bone here it's not a big
deal that would even make a little bit
of sense right but they don't even have
the money that they're trying to give
you yeah a human one into this sort of
thing it was normal no it's not normal
it's weird and they got issues so read
the book boundaries and you'll begin to
understand that here's the problem you
know this up front the book is gonna
tell you this when you set boundaries
with people who don't respect boundaries
you can expect them to become angry
because you put up a fence and they were
used to walking through your yard but
it's your yard and you put up a fence
say I don't get to get mad about not
getting to walk in your yard but they do
sometimes so that's the problem they
don't respect the guidelines they don't
respect the boundaries and so the book
is called boundaries by dr. Henry cloud
it'll help you out a bunch kiddo